[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
نبدا بالعناوين
روسيا تقول انها رصد التقدم مدرعات
امريكيه تحمل مواد كيميائيه سامه نحو خطوط
التماس في اوكرانيا
الحكومه الاوكرانيه تقر بصعوبه الوضع في
بخموت وترجح ان تحدد الاشهر الثلاثه
القادمه مسار الحرب
اعتداءات المستوطنين تشل الحركه في نابلس
والاتحاد الاوروبي يحذر من تصاعد العنف في
الضفه الغربيه
على وقع التوتر الصيني الامريكي في بحر
الصين الجنوبي الفلبين توجه جهود جيشها
لحمايه سواحلها
اتهام شديد اللهجه واجهته وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه لواشنطن بالتخطيط لاستفزازات في
اوكرانيا باستخدام مواد كيميائيه سامه
قائد قوات الحمايه الاشعاعيه والكيميائيه
والبيولوجيه في الجيش الروسي
قال ان قواته رصد التقدم عربات مدرعه
امريكيه الصنع تحوي مواد كيميائيه نحو
خطوط التماس في اوكرانيا استعدادا للقيام
باعمال استفزازيه وعلى وقع التصعيد
العسكري في اوكرانيا وضعت كياف جدولا
زمنيا لحسم مسار المعركه حيث قال رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه كريلو
بودانوف ان الاشهر الثلاثه المقبله على
الجبهه ستكون حاسمه وستقرر مسار الحرب
وخلال مقابله مع اذاعه صوت امريكا اضاف
بودانوف ان روسيا ليست مستعده حاليا لخوض
حرب طويله الامد بسبب نقص الموارد لكنه
اشار ايضا الى حاجه اكياف لامدادات اسلحه
تتضمن طائرات هجوميه وفيما يتعلق بمعركه
بخموت الحاسمه قال قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه اوكسان ان الوضع في محيط مدينه
مخموت اصبح متوترا للغايه وفي رساله على
تيليجرام اوضح الجنرال الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه دفعت باحداث هجوميات تابعه
لمجموعه فاجنر العسكريه في محاوله لاختراق
دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني بهدف فردي حصار
على المدينه وكان الرئيس فلودي ميرسي وصف
الوضع في بخموت وحولها بالصعب واضاف ان
القوات الروسيه تدمر بشكل متواصل كل ما
يمكن استخدامه من قبل الجنود الاوكرانيين
لحمايه انفسهم
في قطاع مخموض يزداد الوضع صعوبه العدو
يدمر باستمرار كل ما يمكن ان نستخدمه
لحمايه مواقعنا للتحصين والدفاع جنودنا
الذين يدافعون عن المنطقه المحيطه بمخموت
هم ابطال حقيقيون
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
اهلا بك رائد يعني يصف المعارك في بخموت
بانها صعبه للغايه ماذا يقول او ماذا تقول
القوات المواليه لروسيا عن معركه بخموت
صباح الخير بالفعل المنطقه هنا تشهد تطورا
كبيرا بالمعارك خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
بشكل عام وليس في محور بخموت وحده كل
المحاور خاصه في مقاطعه المحور الجنوبي
حيث
المدن المتاخمه للعاصمه والحديث عن امار
عن
افديفكا ايضا كهذه المدن تشهد عمليات
عسكريه روسيه
متواصله لا تتوقف الاله العسكريه الروسيه
تقصف باستمرار هذه المدن وتحاول التقدم في
المدن التي سيطرت على اجزاء منها وتحاول
اقتحام بعض المدن التي لم تدخلها حتى الان
الحديث عن 35 الف قذيفه وصاروخ تضرب بشكل
يومي من قبل القوات الروسيه على جميع
المحاور في
المحور الاهم دائما يبقى هو باخموت بالفعل
قوات فاغنر تقاتل في جميع المحاور
الجنوبيه والشرقيه والشماليه من مدينه
باخمت وتقدمت من المحور الجنوبي خلال ايام
وتحاول اقتحام بلده ايفانفكا كما انها في
المحور الشرقي دخلت ايضا الى معامل اللحوم
ودخلت الى
حيبطوطنا
وحيشادره تتقدم عده كيلومترات من الجنوب
ومن الشرقي كما انها بالامس كان لها اول
دخول الى المدينه من الناحيه الشماليه بعد
ان سيطرت على عده بلدات لان هناك دفاعات
اوكرانيه قويه استطاعت امس قوات فاجنر
الدخول الى
ستوبينكي احدى الاحياء وسيطرت على عده
مجمعات سكنيه الحديث ان قوات فاجنر تتقدم
من الناحيه الشماليه الغربيه حيث كانت
بلده ياجد نايا تذكرين كانت هناك بلده
ياجد وسيطر عليها الجيش الروسي
يحاولون اكمال الطوق راويه من الناحيه عن
هذا
باختصار لو سمحت
اود ان اسالك عن الطرق المؤديه الى بخمه
هل تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه الان وهل
ذلك يعني
بانوت مطوقه بشكل كامل امنه من المبكره
الحديث عن تطويقها بشكل كبير
اكيد من المبكر الحديث عن تطويقها بشكل
كبير لكن ربما يعني تفصلنا ايام او اسابيع
يعني اذا اذا طال الوقت السيطره على مدينه
باقمت باتت حتميه حسب تصريحات المسؤولين
هنا قالوا بان السيطره ستكون وشيكه لكن
هناك دفاعات قويه من قبل الجيش الاوكراني
ولابد ان الذخيره ما زالت تصل الى
المقاتلين الاوكرانيين الذين ما زالوا
يعني يتحصنون في جيوب في كل المناطق التي
دخلتها القوات الروسيه او قوات فاجنر
تحديدا يحاول الجيش الروسي هل دخول الى
مركز المدينه قال احد الجنرالات بان
الف وسبع مئه متر فقط تفصيله عن مركز
المدينه مع قواته الحديث عن اقل من كيلو
مترين بالفعل هناك دخول ليس فقط محاولات
اقتحام دخول لمدينه باقمت قتال شوارع لكن
ما زالت القوات الاوكرانيه تقاوم حتى الان
والطرق السريعه التي سالت عنها ما زالت
اظن تعمل لكنها تحت نيران المدفعيه
الروسيه شكرا جزيلا لك من دانيت مراسل
العربيه ر
في اطار توسيع العقوبات ضد روسيا اعلنت
وزاره الخارجيه اليابانيه عن تجميد اصول
39 شخصا وثلاث وسبعين منظمه من روسيا
العقوبات اليابانيه شملت بشكل خاص نائب
وزير الدفاع الروسي فيكتور غوريميكين
وكبار المسؤولين في الاداره الرئاسيه
الروسيه الخارجيه اليابانيه اشارت ايضا
الى ان طوكيو تعمل على تجميد اصول تسعه
اشخاص اضافيين من ادارات مقاطعات خرسون
ولوجانسك
وردا على العقوبات الغربيه اعلنت المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا خروف عن
استعداد موسكو لاجراءات انتقاميه ردا على
العقوبات الامريكيه والكنديه زخروبا وصفت
الاجراءات التي ستتخذها ضد واشنطن
بالاجراءات ذات التاثير المركز مشيره الى
ان العقوبات الروسيه ستنطلق من مبادئ
المعامله بالمثل على حد وصفها وتنضم الينا
من موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعم اهلا
بك كاتيا يعني ماريا زخرفه وصفت هذه
العقوبات الانتقاميه التي يعني ستقرها
موسكو بالمركز ذات التاثير المركز هل من
مؤشرات حول شكلها حول مضمونها الاشخاص
والكيانات ربما
مرحبا راويه بالفعل الخارجيه الروسيه وعلى
الانساني متحدثتها ماريا زخرفه كانت قد
قالت انه ان موسكو سترد على هذه العقوبات
التي فرضتها اوتوا واشنطن على موسكو
وستكون مؤلمه جدا
لكل من هذين الدولتين طبعا كما تحدثت
زخارب انها الرد سيكون بالمثل وكما شاهدنا
كنا دائما وعلى مرارا السنه
السابقه بعد بدء العمليات العسكريه وبدء
فرض العقوبات على شخصيات روسيه وكيانات
ايضا روسيه كانت قد ردت موسكو على جميع
العقوبات التي فرضت بالمثل
طبعا اليوم ايضا من جانب اخر راويه هناك
اجتماع للرئيس الروسي الذي سيعقده مع
الجهاز الامن الفيدر الفيدرالي الروسي وهو
الاجتماع الاول بعد بدء روسيا للعمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا هو سيتحدث
طبعا عن ملخص عمل جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي خلال السنه السابقه
طبعا كما تعلمين كان الجهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي كان يعمل بشكل نشط
للقضاء على الخليات الارهابيه ومحاوله
مكافحه الارهاب في روسيا وبالاخص التي
العمليات التي ازدادت بعد بدء العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه سيكون هناك تلخيص للعمل
هذا الجهاز الامن في السنه السابقه ووضع
خطه للعمل جهاز الامن الفيدرالي في السنه
في هذه السنه طبعا اختصاص عمل جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الذي يتلخص في مكافحه الارهاب
وحمايه الحدود الروسيه ومحاربه التجسس
ايضا
وطبعا بالاخص في ضوء العمليه العسكريه
التي بداتها روسيا في اوكرانيا راويه شكرا
جزيلا لك من موسكو مراسلات العربيه كاتيا
طعمه
اكد رئيس الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه كيريلو
بودانوف انه لا يرى اي مؤشر على ان الصين
تعتزم امداد روسيا باسلحه وقال في تصريحات
لوسائل الاعلام امريكيه انه لا يشاطر
تقييمات مدير وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه
لان بكين تدرس تزويد روسيا باسلحه وهو ما
نفته الصين بشده واضاف بودانوف ان الحقائق
على الارض لا تشير الى مثل هكذا امور وان
روسيا تحاول فقط شراء السلاح لان مشاكلها
كبيره بحسب التعبير خطه الصين لتسويه
الازمه الاوكرانيه بعد اقتراحها باربعه
ايام لاقت ردود فعل متباينه مره اخرى ما
بين متارجح ومرحب واخر يتحفظ برايه الجانب
الروسي وعلى لساني المتحدث باسم الكرام
وصف مبادره بكين بالمتماشيه مع نهج موسكو
وان بلاده تاخذها على محمل التقدير لكن
تفاصيلها بنودها المكونه من اثنتي عشره
نقطه يجب ان تخضع لتحليل دقيق وحسابات وهي
عمليه طويله ومرهقه بحسب بسكوف المتحدث
الروسي اضاف ان الوضع الراهن لا يتيح فرصه
لمناقشه التسويه في اوكرانيا وان العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه ستستمر في اوكرانيا في
الوقت الحالي من جهته وصف رئيس وزراء
المجر فيكتور اوربان الخطه الصينيه
بالمهمه والتي من شانها ان تصل باوكرانيا
واسمتها الى بار السلام اوكرانيا اخذت
موقفا وسطيا من المبادره الصينيه فلا هي
ترفض رفضا قاطعا ولا تبدي موافقه وانما
تشجع على دعم السلام في اوكرانيا ومواجهه
ما اسمته عدوانا روسيا حول هذا الموضوع
انضم الينا من موسكو رائد جابر مدير مكتب
جريده الشرق الاوسط في موسكو عبر سكايب
اهلا بك سيد رائد يعني
موسكو رحبت بالمبادره الصينيه ولكنها بعده
تصريحات تقول نحن الان لسنا مستعدين
للحوار
لم تبدي لا موافقه ولا رفضا كيف يمكن فهم
ان كان يمكن تسميته تناقدا في الموقف
الروسي
نعم تحيه طيبه هو ليست تناقد موسكو ترحب
عموما باي جهد تقوم به الصين لانه تعتبر
انه الصين حليف وشريك اساسي بالنسبه اليها
وانه لن تتعارض سياسه الصينيه مع السياسه
الروسيه على صعيد المسرح الدولي على يعني
اتجاه النظام الدولي الجديد الذي تريد
موسكو
هذه المبادره بالتحديد المضمون الذي تقدمت
به هو لا يلبي تماما مصالح موسكو يعني
يكفي ان نتذكر انه البند الاول من هذه
المبادره يقوم على احترام سياده ووحده
اراضي البلدان
وعدم التدخل في شؤونها وما الى ذلك هذا
يتعارض تماما مع الموقف الروسي الذي يعني
اقتطع اجزاء من اوكرانيا وضمها بشكل رسمي
الى روسيا اذا هناك تفاصيل لا تستطيع
موسكو ان ترحب بها كثيرا مع ترحيبها العام
هذه مشكله جديه هذا سؤال اشكالي يعني لانه
روسيا تقول رفعت سقفها عاليه جدا وتقول
اننا لن تتراجع عن ضم الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لن تتراجع عن موضوع شبه جزيره القرم
بالتالي هذه النقطه مفصليه اي مبادره سوف
لقيام موسكو بخطوات مماثله ربما يعني
تبرير
يعني لا يمكن استبعاد اي سيناريو لكن اذكر
هنا انه موسكو كانت اكثر من مره اتهمت كيف
تحضير الاستفزازات كيماويه واحيانا
استفزازات حتى قرب منشات حساسه مثل منشاه
النوويه مثلا وانه كل هذه الاستفزازات
تهدف الى توجيه الاتهامات الى موسكو الان
هذه الاتهامات تتسع يعني
هي من تحضر لهذا للقيام بهذه الاستفزازات
لا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في الحقيقه لم
توضح تفاصيل وكيف حصلت على معطياتها انه
بالفعل واشنطن ربما تكون طالعه في هذا
الامر ولكن في كل في كل الاحوال هذا مؤشر
الى انه درجه سخونه الاوضاع تتزايد درجه
يعني القلق من اتساع رقعه المعركه يتزايد
هناك حديث كما تعلمين عن اقليم
الانفصال الذي قالت ايضا موسكو ان هناك
استفزازات تجري في هذا الاقليم بالتالي
نحن امام مشهد ربما ذاهب بشكل متسارع نحو
توسيع نطاق المعركه بعض الشيء
لكن الحديث عن استفزازات من دون تقديم
براهين وادله انه كيف حصلت مشكله هذه
المعطيات وكيف ستقول الولايات المتحده
باستفزاز كيماوي على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
هذا امر ليس مفهوما بعد نعم والان تتحدث
عن تعليق الرحلات الجويه مؤقتا من مطار
مدينه سامبا الروسيه شكرا جزيلا لك رائد
جابر مدير مكتب جريده الشرق الاوسط في موس
كو نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
زلزال تركيا الاضرار تتجاوز الاربعه مليار
دولار واعاده الاعمار ستضاعف الرقم
اعتداءات المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه حذر
الاتحاد الاوروبي من تصاعدي العنف ودعا
الى ضروره التهدئه فورا وقد شهدت العديد
من البلدات في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
اعتداءات من المستوطنين واحراق سيارات
ومواجهات عنيفه بين فلسطينيين والقوات
الاسرائيليه وتحديدا في جنوب نابلس وجنوب
جنين وبعض بلدات القدس ورام الله وبحسب
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه اعتدى مستوطنون
على سياره اسعاف اثناء مرورها من زعتره في
جنين حيث كانت تنقل طفله مريضه الى قسم
العنايه المركزه بمستشفى في رام الله وقد
اصيبت والده الطفله بجروح جراء تكسير
المستوطنين لزجاج الاسعاف
مجزره
جيب عسكري دخل بالخطا الى قريه ميته
[موسيقى]
وبظل استمرار اعتداءات المستوطنين علقت
جامعه النجاح الوطني ومديريه التربيه
والتعليم في جنوب نابلس دوام الطلبه اليوم
وغدا وبدات التعليم عن بعد ياتي هذا
القرار تزامنا مع دفع اسرائيل المزيد من
التعزيزات العسكريه للضفه الغربيه المحتله
عبر فرض طوق امني على المدينه وحشد كتيبه
عسكريه رابعه في محاوله لتعزيز عمليات
مطارده منفذ عمليتي اريحا وحواره حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا من رام الله مراسل
عربيه خالد قاسم اهلا بك خالد يعني اخر
التطورات وكيف يبدو المشهد من عندك
لم تكن بالسهله يوم امس مرت على الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وتحديدا في محيط مدينه اريحا
ومحيط بلده حواره جراء اعتداءات
المستوطنين المتواصله منذ يومين على
مركبات ومنازل
الفلسطينيين
الطواقم الصحفيه
والطواقم الطبيه تتعرض
للاعتداءات كما ذكرتي راويه في بدايه
الخبر الاعتداء على سياره اسعاف كانت تقل
طفله من مستشفى في نابلس الى مستشفى في
رام الله للعنايه المركزه تم رشق المركبه
بالحجاره اصيبت الوالده بجراح الاعتداءات
على الصحفيين ايضا متواصله من قبل
المستوطنين في مختلف المناطق قوات كبيره
من الجيش الاسرائيلي وقوى الامن
الاسرائيليه ما تزال تبحث عن منفذ عمليه
حواره التي اودت ادت الى مقتل مستوطنين
اثنين
يوم السبت الماضي كما تبحث ايضا عن الخليه
التي نفذت عمليه
صدم مركبه واطلاق النار على سائقها ما ادى
الى مقتل مستوطن في محيط مدينه اريحا طبعا
هذا يشمل
مداهمه منازل الفلسطينيين في مخيم عقبه
جبر وفي محيط مدينه اريحا ايضا
مداهمه منازل الفلسطينيين في محيط بلده
حواره في محاوله
للتعقب اثار منفذ عمليات حواره يوم السبت
الماضي خالد او ان اسالك عن الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه التي اتذكرت فعل يعني هناك
حديث عن اغلاق معبر الكرامه مع الاردن
والمزيد من الحواجز العسكريه للتفتيش في
نابلس وايضا افق التهدئه
يعني بالنسبه الى بلده حواره يسمح بالخروج
منها ولا يسمح بالدخول اليها المحل
التجاريه
بقرار من الجيش الاسرائيلي يمنع اصحابها
من فتح ابوابها منذ منذ يوم السبت حتى هذا
اليوم معبر القرار الكرامه مغلق للمغادرين
باتجاه الاراضي الاردنيه
وهناك تدقيق واعاقات للقدمين عبر المعبر
طبعا حواجز مدينه اريحا جميعها
مغلقه الا بعض الطرق الفرعيه التي يسلكها
الفلسطينيون للدخول او للخروج الى المدينه
تشديدات على الحواجز العسكريه من شمال
الضفه الى
جنوبها لتفتيش للمركبات ايضا انتشار
لسيارات الشرطه الاسرائيليه التي تحرر
المخالفات للمركبات الفلسطينيه بداء او
بدون سبب شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله مراسل
العربيه خالد القاسم
رحب مجلس النواب الليبي بالمبادره الامميه
التي تهدف الى اجراء انتخابات حره ونزيهه
وثمن المجلس دور البعثه الامميه في هذا
الصدد واكد المجلس على ان الليبيين هم
الضامن الوحيد لانجاح اي مبادرات في هذا
الشان وطلب مجلس النواب في بيان المجتمع
الدولي بدعم المؤسسات الليبيه كما اعرب
المجلس عن رفضه التام لاي تدخل في الشان
الليبي والمساسي بجهود المؤسسات الامنيه
وانضم الينا من طرابلس مراسل العربيه منير
الاشهب اهلا بك منير يعني وقع المبادره
الامميه الجديده لاجراء الانتخابات على
الاطراف الليبيه هنالك من تفاؤل ام انه
يمكن ان تكون نتائجها
السابقات من المبادرات التي فشلت
منير هل تسمعني
يبدو ان منير لا يسمعني سنحاول الاتصال به
ربما خلال النشره ونتابع ونذهب الى تركيا
حيث قدر البنك الدولي خسائر تركيا الماديه
المباشره جراء الزلزالين الكبيرين في
السادس من فبراير بنحو 34 مليار و200
مليون دولار مرجحا ان تكون اجماليه تكاليف
اعاده الاعمار والتعافي التي تواجهها
البلاد قد يكون ضعفي ذلك
اربعه وثلاثون مليارا و200 مليون دولار
قيمه اضرار الزلزالين في تركيا
تكاليف اعاده الاعمار والتعافي في تركيا
بعد زلزالي السادس من فبراير قد يكون ضعفي
ذلك
بحسب تقديرات البنك الدولي سيخفض
الزلزالان ايضا ما لا يقل عن نصف نقطه
مئويه من نمو الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
المتوقعه لتركيا هذا العام بين 3.5 واربعه
في المئه هذا ما قاله مدير مكتب البنك
الدولي في تركيا
اعقبت الزلزالين مما تسبب في اكبر كارثه
من هذا النوع تشهدها تركيا منذ اكثر من 80
عاما تقرير البنك الدولي يشير الى ان
مليون و250 الف شخص اصبحوا بلا ماوى بسبب
الاضرار التي لحقت بمنازلهم او انهيارها
بشكل كامل
البيت الدولي قدم مساعده فوريه قيمتها 780
مليون دولار لتركيا بالاضافه الى مليار
دولار في مشروع تعاف طارئ جديد
هاتاي بانتظارك شعار يتم تداوله
على سكان بلده كارخان الحدوديه مع سوريا
يحاولون العوده تدريجيا الى حياتهم
الطبيعيه رغم اثار الزلزال المحيطه بهم من
كل جانب
يعني
من اجل مواصله الحياه والبقاء في البلاد
والحفاظ عليها رغم الزلازل ومخلفاتها يجب
علينا استئناف عملنا لتستمر الحياه
خلال الزلزال قتل ما يقارب سته الاف شخص
من ابناء هذه البلده التي كان تعداد
سكانها يفوق الاربع مئه الف نسمه نصفهم من
السوريين
والله على الله شفت عينك يعني
انشغل
الله يعزك شغلات مضبطين امورنا وقبل زلزال
كان وضعكم احسن والله
حالتنا تعبانه نقول لك فوق الرحله
والله بيوتنا نفوت بيها
انا نقول نجذب نفوت على البيت مثل الحرامي
ناخذ قرض ونطلع
هذه واحده من عشرات المساحات الجارفه
لتتحول الى مدن مؤقته الفحاويه ببلده
كارخان يتم تجهيزها لتكون مساكن صالحه
لاواء الاف المتضررين من ضحايا الزلزال
عبد القادر خربوش العربيه بلده كارخان على
الحدود التركيه السوريه
وينضم الينا من جديد منير الاشب مراسل
العربيه حول المبادره الامميه الجديده
لاجراء الانتخابات التي اطلقها المبعوث
الاماميه عبد الله باتيلي اهلا بك من جديد
منير يعني ما وقع هذه المبادره الامميه
على الاطراف الليبيه
اهلا بك نعم كانت عبد الله
كالعاده يعني شكلت ردود فعل مختلفه وشكلت
حتى انقسام سياسي جديد لربما يبداون في
ليبيا خصوصا ما تحدثنا ان الحكومه الليبيه
التي يتناسا فتحي باشاغه عن طريقها وزاره
خارجيتها يعني ادالت تجاوز عبد الله بتيلي
لها وعدم ذكره لها في
احطته وكانه تجاوز الحكومه فيما رحب بعض
بعض المرشحين السياسيين في هذه المبادره
املا منهم ان تقام الانتخابات التي اجرت
لاكثر من عام هنا نذكر محمد الشاوش وايضا
سيف الاسلام القذافي وغيره من المترشحين
الذين رحبوا بشكل مباشر وفوري بعد يعني
مباشره بهذا بهذه الايحاء فيما ننتظر ايضا
رد فعل الرسمي من حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
هنا في طرابلس حاولنا التواصل مع
المسؤولين لرصد يعني ردود افعالهم هل هناك
ترحيب ام هناك يعني رفض لهذه المبادره
ولكن لم نتحصل على هذه الساعه نحن في
انتظار ردود رسمية من المرشحين وايضا من
الجهات الفاعله هنا رسميا سواء من المجلس
الدوله المجلس الاعلى للدوله او حتى حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه بعد ما رصدنا يعني
الترحيب او شبه ترحيب من مجلس النواب
وتحفظها على بعض الميقات وايضا يعني رفض
الحكومه الليبيه التي يتلاشى فتحي بشاخه
لهذه المبادره التي قدمها عبد الله امام
مجلس الامن ايضا في انتظار القوه الفاعله
على الارض والتشكيلات المسلحه ما هو رايها
في هذه الاحاطه ولكن عفوا ولكن مره صدناها
من خلال الشارع هو ترحيب باجراء
الانتخابات في اي وقت ممكن اي مبادله تفضي
الى الانتخابات والذهاب الى مؤسسات رسميه
شرعيه ينتخبها الشعب الليبي هي مرحب بها
هنا في الشارع الشارع يعمل ان تنتهي
معه المعاناه وان تبعد عنهم شبح الحرم نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك منير الاشهب من طرابلس
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
تصعيد الحد ضد التيك توك والصين ترفض قرار
واشنطن بحظر التطبيق تابعونا
روسيا تقول انها رصدت تقادم مدرعات
امريكيه تحمل مواد كيميائيه سامه نحو خطوط
التماس في اوكرانيا
الحكومه الاوكرانيه تقر بصعوبه الوضع في
بخموت وترجح ان تحدد الاشهر الثلاثه
القادمه مسار الحرب
اعتداءات المستوطنين تشل الحركه في نابلس
والاتحاد الاوروبي يحذروا من تصاعد العنف
في الضفه الغربيه
على وقع التوتر الصيني الامريكي في بحر
الصين الجنوبي الفلبين توجه جهود جيشها
لحمايه سواح
اهلا بكم من جديد نتوقف مع الخبر العاجل
الذي ورد قبل قليل حيث اكد التقارير روسيه
تعليق المجال الجوي فوق مدينه بطرسبرج
الروسيه حتى منتصف النهار وذلك بعد رصدي
تحليق لجسم غير معروف في السماء واقلع
طائرات مقاتله للاستطلاع واشار موقع فلاي
رادار الى ان عددا من الرحلات الداخليه
المتجهه الى سامبودريس عادت الى محل
اقلاعها
شدد الرئيس الفلبينيي فرنانوند ماركوس
الابن في خطاب القهوه امام جيش بلاده ان
المهمه الاساسيه للجيش تغيرت الى ضمان
حمايه اراضيه نتيجه لتنام النزاعات مع
الصين والتنافس الامريكيه الصيني ياتي
خطاب ماركوس بعد اسبوعين من استدعاء صفير
الصين للاحتجاج على استخدام قوات خفر
السواحل الصينيه ضوء الليزر يستخدم لاغراض
عسكريه تسبب في عمى مؤقت لعدد من بحاره
سفينه فلبينيه في بحر الصين الجنوبي
تعهد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتن بلينك
بتعزيز وتقويه العلاقات مع خمسين من دول
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق في اسيا الوسطى
جاء ذلك خلال زيارته الى كازاخستان حيث
اكد دعمه الاستقلالها ومن المقرر ان يلتقي
بلنكن في استانا وزراء خارجيه قرقيستان
وطاجيكستان وتركمان اضافه الى اوزباكستان
بحثا عن تعزيز النفود الامريكيه خاصه ان
دول اسيا الوسطى تتمتع بعلاقات امنيه
واقتصاديه طويله الامد مع روسيا وامتنعت
الدول الخمس عن التصويت في الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده على قرار يطالب روسيا
بالانسحاب من اوكرانيا
اشهد رئيس وزراء
ماليجا بالامدادات العسكريه الروسيه مشيرا
الى انها ساعدت على عكس مسار المعركه ضد
الارهاب لصالح القوات المسلحه واضاف مايجا
ان التعاون العسكري مع روسيا سيستمر في
الفتره المقبله في اطار تعزيز قوات الامن
والدفاع وكان وزير الخارجيه الروسي
سيرجيلا
في السابع من فبراير حيتاكد ان روسيا
ارسلت دفعه كبيره من الطائرات للجيش
المالي
خرق كبير حققته بريطانيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي بتوصل الى اتفاق لتعديل بروتوكول
ينظم التجاره في ايرلندا الشماليه ويرمي
الى احتواء التوترات التي يؤججها
الاتفاق الذي اعلنه رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشيسونا ورئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه
ينص على اقامه ممر اخضر معفى من عمليات
التفتيش للسلع الوافده من بريطانيا الى
ايرلندا الشماليه كما يحد من اشراف محكمه
العدل الاوروبيه على البروتوكول
ما كان مستعصيا على اسلافه حققه رئيس
الحكومه البريطانيه اذ توصل الى اتفاق مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي لحل مشاكل البروتوكول
ايرلندا الشماليه الذي يخضع هذا الاقليم
التابعه للتاج البريطاني بعد البريكزيت
لقوانين السوق الاوروبيه الموحده للحفاظ
على حدود مفتوحه بين ايرلندا الشماليه
وجارتها الجنوبيه العضو في الاتحاد
الاوروبي كما يفرض اجراءات تفتيش جمركيه
للبضائع من انحاء بريطانيا الى هذه
المقاطعه الشماليه سوناك اشاد بهذا
الاختراق الحاسم
يسعدني ان ابلغكم اننا حققنا تقدما حاسما
معا قمنا بتغيير البروتوكول الاصلي ونعلن
اليوم عن اطار عمل الدستور الجديد توفر
اتفاقيه اليوم تدفقا ثالثا للتجاره داخل
المملكه المتحده باكملها وتحمي مكانه
ايرلندا الشماليه في اتحادنا وتحمي
السياده لشعب ايرلندا الشماليه
اطار عمل وينزر جاء نتيجه التوتر الذي
اثاره بروتوكول ارنادا الشماليه بتعطيل
عمل السلطه التنفيذيه المحليه لاكثر من
سنه ناهيك عن بيروقراطيه نقل البضائع الى
المقاطعه الشماليه وستتيح هذه التسويه
الجديده توافر جميع المواد الغذائيه
والادويه البريطانيه في اسواق ارلوندا
الشماليه عبر مسارين واحد اخضر للبضائع
المتوجهه لايرلندا الشماليه واخر احمر
للبضائع الذي قد تتوجه للاتحاد الاوروبي
كما تعطي المجلس المحلي رايا في القوانين
الاوروبيه التي تحكمهم
لقد توصلنا الى اتفاق في اطار عمل يفرض
تسويه جديده فيما يخص ايرلندا وايرلندا
الشماليه اطار العمل سيكون بدايه لفصل
جديد بيننا ويؤمن حلولا طويله الامد والتي
ستناسب الجميع في ايرلندا الشماليه
ان الاتفاق الجديد مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
بشان بروتوكول ايرلندا الشماليه يصحح عيوب
والتحدي الذي يواجه ريشيس هناك الان هو
اقناع الاطراف السياسيه هنا في بريطانيا
لقبول هذه التسويه الجديده
على راس هؤلاء الحزب الوحدوي الديمقراطي
الذي جمد صيغه تقاسم السلطه وفق معاهده
السلام بسبب البروتوكول الذي اثر على
التجاره بين بريطانيا وايروندا الشماليه
لابقاء هذه المقاطعه في السوق الموحده كما
سيكون على السوناك كسب اعضاء حزبه وخاصه
جناحه المتشدده في مجموعه الابحاث
الاوروبيه فيما ابدت المعارضه تاييدها
للاتفاق لازاله عقبات وتصحيح اخطاء
البروتوكول السابق مصطفى العربيه لندن
كشف تقرير امريكي حكومي ان حكومه
افغانستان السابقه تفاجات بانسحاب القوات
الامريكيه وقالت تقرير الذي نشرته صحيفه
تم ان الحكومه السابقه عند الانسحاب من
البلاد بالدعم الامني وهو ما لم يحدث
18 شهرا مرت على الانسحاب الامريكي من
افغانستان
صعدت بعده مباشره حركه طالبان الى السلطه
مغيره المشهد السياسي بشكل جذري في البلد
الذي عانى لسنوات
الانسحاب الامريكي فاجا الحكومه السابقه
في افغانستان وفق تقرير حكومي نشرته صحيفه
التقرير الذي جرى بطلب من الكونجرس
الامريكي والذي سيناقشه قريبا اتهم
البنتاجون بعدم التعاون مع التحقيق حول
انهيار الجيش الافغاني وانه لم يقدم الدعم
الامني للحكومه الافغانيه السابقه كما وعد
ضمن بنود الانسحاب مما سمح بانهيار الجيش
والحكومه وصعود طالبان الى السلطه خلال
ايام معدوده
كما اشار الى تقديم البنتاجون لاجابات غير
كامله على الاسئله لترد وزاره الدفاع
بدورها انها تعاونت مع التحقيق قائله انها
قدمت ردودا مكتوبه على اسئله المفتش العام
جورنال نقلا عن التقرير الامريكي القت
باللوم على اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن التي لم تلتزم باتفاق انسحاب القوات
الامريكيه بين طالبان واداره ترامب ما ادى
لانتقادات بين الحزبين الرئيسيين طالت
الرئيس بايدن عدا عن الاتهامات بسوء تخطيط
الانسحاب وعدم الاهتمام بحمايه المتعاقدين
الافغان كما كشفت المعلومات عن ترك
الولايات المتحده معدات عسكريه وراءها في
افغانستان بقيمه تزيد عن سبعه مليارات
دولار بين الطائرات وصواريخ واسلحه ومعدات
اتصال
سبعه مليارات دولار من المعدات الصالحه
للعمل من اصل 18 مليارا انفقتها امريكا
على تسليح الجيش الافغاني الذي انهار في
ساعات معدوده
التقرير ختم باهميه عدم تكرار التجربه
الافغانيه في اوكرانيا منبها الى ضروره
مراقبه المساعدات العسكريه التي تقدمها
الولايات المتحده لكييف قائلا ان التورط
الامريكي في هذه الصراعات اظهر عدم القدره
على التعلم من الاخطاء
حتى زعيم كوريا الشماليه
المسؤولين الحكوميين على ضروره اجراء
تغيير جذري في الانتاج الزرعي وفق ما ذكرت
وكاله الانباء المركزي الكوريه واكد زعيم
كوريا الشماليه ان التغييرات يجب ان تحدث
في السنوات القليله المقبله قائلا ان
تحقيق اهداف انتاج الحبوب هذا العام
اولويه قصوى عبر ايجاد مهام فوريه واهداف
علميه طويله المدى من اجل ما اسماه تحولا
اساسيا للتنميه المستقره والمستدامه
للزراعه
اعربت الخارجيه الصينيه عن رفضها لقرار
البيت الابيض بشان حظر تطبيق تيك توك
وقالت المتحدثه باسم الوزاره ماونينج ان
القرار يعبر عن اجراءاتماعيه ضد الشركات
الاجنبيه ويتجاوز الامن القومي مشيره الى
ان الصين ترفض القرار وتعارضه من جهه اخرى
اكدت ان بكين ستشارك في اجتماع وزراء
خارجيه مجموعه العشرين المقرر في نيودلهي
مشيره الى ان الصين مستعده للعملين مع
جميع الاطراف للتركيز على التحديات
العالميه قيود تيك توك في امريكا تتزايد
فقد امهل البيت الابيض الهيئات الحكوميه
30 يوما لتاكدي من عدم وجود هذا التطبيق
على اي من الاجهزه او الانظمه التابعه
للحكومه الاتحاديه وقالت مديره مكتب
الاداره والميزانيه شالندا يونج للجهه
الحكوميه في مذكره توجيهيه انه سيكون
مطلوبا منها تعديل عقود تكنولوجيا
المعلومات للتاكد من ان المتعاقدين يحمون
بيانات الولايات المتحده من خلال وقف
استهداف او استخدام تيك توك على الاجهزه
والانظمه المستخدمه في اطار عملهم من
جانبها حضرت الحكومه الكنديه تطبيق تيك
توك على كل هواتفها واجهزتها مشيره الى
مخاوف على صعيد حمايه البيانات وجاء ذلك
في بيان الحكومه وانه اعتبارا من اليوم
الثلاثاء سيتم حذف تطبيق تيك توك عن
الاجهزه المحموله التي تمنحها الحكومه كما
سيتم منع مستخدمي هذه الاجهزه من تنزيل
التطبيق في المستقبل
استعاد الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تسلا الون
ماسك لقب الرجل الاغنى في العالم بعدما حل
في المركز الثاني في قائمه مليارديرات
العالم لاكثر من شهرين في نهايه عام 2022
وذلك وفقا لوكاله انباء بلومبرج الدوليه
والتي اوضحت ايضا ان الصافي ثروه ماسك
تجاوزت 187 مليار دولار بعد ارتفاع اسهم
شركته التسلح
اخر قيود كورونا فقد اعلنت السلطات عن
الغاء الشرط وضع الكمامه في الاماكن
العامه المغلقه وذلك اعتبارا من يوم غد
ليكون ذلك اخر قيود كورونا التي تتخلى
عنها هونج كونج السلطات اوضحت ايضا ان رفع
قيود كورونا يشمل كافه الاماكن العامه
الداخليه والخارجيه بالاضافه الى وسائل
النقل
الكشف عن منشا فيروس كورونا عاده ليطرح
المزيد من الجدل ويزيد من حدد التوتر
الحاصل بين الصين والولايات المتحده
وتحديدا الجمهوريون الذين يرون ان محاسبه
الضروريه بعد ان كشف تقرير امريكي ان
الفيروس تسرب من مختبر صيني
جوله جديده من العراق السياسي سببها هذه
المره تقرير حكومي امريكي حول منشا فيروس
كورونا من انه خرج بسبب حادث من مختبر
صيني في وهران وفق تقرير لموقع اكسيوس فان
الكشف عن منشا كورونا زاد من حده التوتر
بين الولايات المتحده والصين وطرح تململا
واستياء كبيرين في اوساط الاعضاء البارزين
في الحزب الجمهوري الذين لطالما وجهوا
اصابع الاتهام حيث يرون بان النتيجه التي
تم الكشف عنها من طرف مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه الامريكي تثبت انهم كانوا على
حق طوال الوقت الماضي بخصوص تسرب الفيروس
من مختبر صيني لم يكن عن قصد ولم يكن ضمن
برنامج عسكري تعمل عليه بكين وانما بسبب
حادث لم تتضح اسبابه بعد لكن التقرير يطحن
كل النظريات تزامنت مع الجائحه والقى
باللوم على الصين بانها وراء الوباء ما
يفتح الباب مستقبلا للمحاسبه والتعويض بعد
التقرير ارتفعت الاصوات المطالبه بالسياسه
اكثر صرامه مع الصين بدفع من الخلافات
التي تشهدها العلاقات بين واشنطن وبيكين
كل ذلك والصين ترفض الاتهامات لكنها وحتى
الان لم تقدم اي تفسير او دليل على مصدر
الفيروس
روسيا تقول انها رصد التقدم مدرعات
امريكيه تحمل مواد كيميائيه سامه نحو خطوط
التماس في اوكرانيا
الحكومه الاوكرانيه تقر بصعوبه الوضع في
باخموت وترجح ان تحدد الاشهر الثلاثه
القادمه مسار الحرب
اعتداءات المستوطنين تشل الحركه في نابلس
والاتحاد الاوروبي يحذر من تصاعد العنف في
الضفه الغربيه
على وقع التوتر الصيني الامريكي في بحر
الصين الجنوبي الفلبين تواجه جهود جيشها
لحمايه سواحلها
العربيه دوت نت للمزيد من الاخبار
والتحليلات الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]